leo kuck walek ist vielleicht der
älteste schwimmlehrer der welt einmal
pro woche kommt er in die schwimmhalle
in berlin lichterfelde
hier vergisst er dass er in diesem jahr
100 jahre alt geworden ist
denn schwimmen ist seine große
leidenschaft
[Musik]
und sie sind vermutlich ein weiterer
grund für seine langlebigkeit und seine
vitalität früher hat leo kuck weil ich
als schlosser gearbeitet als er vor 40
jahren in rente ging wollte er seine
freizeit sinnvoll nutzen
er macht eine ausbildung zu
schwimmlehrer seitdem bringt cleo
kowalik berliner kindern das schwimmen
bei
zu freuen
wir sind
mehr als 1000 kinder haben mittlerweile
bei ihm die ersten schwimmzüge gelernt
dass die lehrer 100 jährige ist gefällt
ihnen
[Applaus]
gefüllt
das ist wirklich cool dass wir ein
lehrer haben der 102 jahre alt ist ich
mag ist dass wir so ein alten lehrer
haben seine kollegen bewunderten sie
auch sehr stolz drauf und er ist noch so
topfit ist die seilbahn weil er hat
immer noch humor
er kann aber mit den kindern umgehen und
das in der seele ja ich kann jeden
quatsch praktisch mitmachen noch ein
bisschen älter werden empfehlen sich so
alt vielleicht hat das mit seinen
schülern zu tun
sie erwarten dass er ins wasser springt
jeden donnerstag so lange es geht
ich darf
warum würden